الروح بخطوتين الى مصر
في مصر تسمع كلمات كثيره غريبه بعض الشيء
مثل غتت ونيح
وترى للي وغيرها من الشغله او غير الالفاظ
الجديده للجيل الجديد هذه الالفاظ يتخاطب
فيها المصريون في تعاملاتهم اليوميه طبعا
هذه الكلمات في الاصل مفردات فرعونيه على
ما يبدو كان يتحدث بها الفراعنه وقدماء
المصريين استمرت منذ 7000 عام وحتى اليوم
هذه المصطلحات امتزجت مع الجمل والعبارات
المصريه والعربيه حتى تجاوزت الاف الكلمات
سواء في الطعام او العادات الاجتماعيه
وحتى في الدعابه بعضها تغير واخر بقي بنفس
اللفظ والمعنى فمثلا كلمه نونو وتعني
الطفل الصغير وايضا اكله البصاره الشهيره
بقيت كما هي وتعني الفول المطبوخ من هنا
طلب خبراء اثار مصريون بالتسجيل كل ذلك
وتوثيقه والحفاظ عليه كتراث مصريه خالص
على فكره انا عندي لسه اسئله مش بس على
الكلمات كان نفسي مثلا اعرف بتعرف مثل
مصري فيه سبع البرمبه او شو البرمبه
لا هي ربما على فكره في بعض الامثال او
الكلمات
بس هي هي واضحه كانت ولكن يعني والله انا
بحثت كثير ومعرفتش لهلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات